because this is so small this is why
people take out loads right loans cost a
lot of money but it's because you don't
have access to the right amount of money
without taking a look are you quite even
fire decent power that can make you can
wedge ankle and insurance has like it
suppliers well if she had the harsh she
wouldn't need fair haha this is true
this is true okay a regular puppy yeah
yes okay so really carefully with me
she's trying to go through this right
now this is one of the beauties of
budgeting right but Jimmy helps you see
into the future if you're just living
week to week like for example these
kinds of things here they were over here
for life through positive blood and it
is like oh well what a beacon that i
know i went to demo and then been here
at here imma bags and a bit of a hollow
my point okay so therefore this allows
us to forecast right so she try to save
the guy was horny she wants to go in
three years right but she's getting in
trouble no we need to show why that is
and then we need to solve it okay so
yeah it's three times 2200 okay good so
three years worth of savings welcome
back to it like that that's what i'm
calculating three years of savings this
2202 is how much she's getting every
single year so therefore i multiply that
by three and that gives us the figure
which on her current budget that's how
much she's going to get saved at the end
of you you can see this is a wearing
shortfall right we're not going to make
it ok we're going to say in fact before
she will be what's the difference
between how much you trying to say and
this amount
it's almost large ending it over in fact
1293 either Sonya right I was happiness
1293 okay so we are sure that we're
short of God right like it doesn't seem
that big in the scheme of Hammonds like
in the scheme of somebody Anya only
almost 25 grand a year but when you go
over all of these dances and how long
you going for sure so we've already
answered happy now I see will she will
she be able to make a you know a
different time yeah now what's the
obvious things to target right like you
have a look at these know there's kind
of yeah two different categories of
expenses she's got right somehow what we
call like they're essential right so
they're non-negotiable which ones do you
pick up oh ok bored it's not going to
get any worse in fact this is pretty
good rate football and she's got a jew i
have bought um so bored is like what is
kind of life it's kind of like ranch
except you're like you're still living
with someone so you're paying them for
the right yeah hopefully she is armed
she's gonna have to fix up that
somewhere right we can't even think of
extra expenses yet we're already not
making the current now hope you guys can
see the fans are probably going to get
to get her to work so they're also
non-negotiable there are true the
obvious right what are the 12 years 20
entertainment which is weakly and now
see I don't know personal items like
maybe they did include stuff but you
really actually like it item it it's a
bit bad right it's a bit bad
they're true I don't know I can think of
is indeed to be what every fortnight
that you really yeah I agree okay let's
check this out little bit of sexy so
what I let you drive down first thing in
part c is okay your level Oh like sorry
it's the right discussion to have I just
want you to have the right time and
nails like that so I think we've already
identified easy targets but we don't
even really know what we're going to do
with those times want to identify
tonight so I think I wants to come back
to hear right notice and put up the
color around this ring this one doesn't
really know very well this number is
critically important this is the short
form it's only the course of three years
yeah over the course of three years so
if I want to hit this target I need to
save an extra certain amount per year
and this is three years right so I'm
gonna say extra this is party extra
savings needed we'll talk about that the
same the exercise did I gotta be this
but I'm going to find x 3 3rd annual
rate right so that's 431 if I'm doing
mine that's right 481 per year okay now
you better two per year it makes sense
because remember look the original
question was an annual budget ok so I'm
going to find a monthly budget I convert
to a little bit but I have anymore okay
so if I need an extra August squeeze out
an extra 4 30
let's have a look at our entertainers
now this is weekly right now I could get
an exact enough that's too hard to keep
in my brain but what is it nice round
about if I do it 52 times in a year it's
going to get me to this or just over
would you say [ __ ] is what I dollars a
week maybe then [ __ ] photos were using
and getting up at ten well ten dollars a
week every week at 52 weeks that's five
hundred twenty dollars so option one
option will being reduce your weekly
entertainment venue reduce your weekly
entertainment spending to 110 per week
instead of 120 so that will be a saving
all what do we say that's ten dollars
every week 52 weeks 520 that'll get us
there okay and then some which is not
one this week I know okay second option
we said we look at clothes it's
important we do this differently because
you can see clothes are purchase on
different bases right they're not as
frequent thankfully ok so it every month
so therefore I need to think about
something that happens not 52 times a
year but 12 times be right so option two
is reduce the monthly clothes spending
now we knew this is ayman trim per week
ok I want something that happens 12
times a year if I went say twenty bucks
twenty bucks a month come on twenty
bucks x 12 months is too and 40 I'm not
there I'm still pretty sure right hello
30 bucks a month is that going to get
there that's only going to be 360 ok but
when I cross over to be seven forty
dollars a month reducing by that much 40
hours per month is going to be 40 times
well it's for a right I passed the
threshold on there so i'm going to say
instead of 330 per month how much I 730
I took off for you right so it's gonna
be 29 290 Smurfs must deal waiting so
that says
boy